[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elles sont interminables et jingle donc
dylan vous avez fait ces missions dating
nous avons un un professionnel un psy en
tous les cas un docteur en psychologie
monsieur de se taire bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes responsable du casting de
l'émission mario premier regard alors
ces tarifs et le testing c'est moi en
tous cas qui contribue avec deux autres
experts à choisir les personnes qui
peuvent aller ensemble ils sont
compatibles
mario bros des regards étaient donc de
retour sur m6 c'était lundi dernier me
semble-t-il louis saha marcher
correctement même plus que l'année
dernière 3 millions 300 mille et les
salles très bien aux gression de 25% sur
une saison eh ben c'est beaucoup trop
voici notre mari au premier regard les
missions des inconnus doivent se dire
oui sans s'être jamais vu auparavant a
fait son grand retour sur m6 lundi soir
pour cette troisième saison la
production a mis le paquet pour
crédibiliser le programme avec des
experts et la science et oui pour eux
l'amour c'est de la science est donc ça
peut se calculer et 6 et pas n'importe
comment en plus sain grâce
à des algorithmes scientifique nous
allons former des couples compatibles et
a priori leur super ordinateurs sont
ultra ultra précis halloween et florian
sont compatibles à 80 3% avec une
compatibilité de 82%
ah oui ça se joue au centième bref et
c'est en ça que ça va fonctionner alors
on souhaite évidemment aux candidats de
cette année que ça fonctionne mais sur
les saisons précédentes seul un couple
sur neuf n'a pas divorcé soit à peine
plus de 10% on est bien loin des 80 % de
compatibilité la caméra alors on est
quand même en droit de se poser des
questions déjà est ce que l'amour c'est
vraiment scientifique et surtout est ce
que le système de calcul des experts est
vraiment efficace c'est la meilleure
solution pour prendre la bonne décision
le jour j meilleure solution on ne sait
pas mais en tout cas cette méthode de
compatibilité scientifique est utilisé
dans d'autres émissions comme dans
l'es10 couple parfait par exemple
vont d'autres solutions sont également
utilisés dans certaines émissions de
dating
dans la villa des coeurs brisés c'est la
psychologue et love coach lucie mariotti
qui tente d'aider et de résoudre les
problèmes amoureux des candidats ça va
ça va tu n'as aucune capacité à la
frustration donc en fait la vie est
faite entre autres de frustration on ne
sait pas si ça les aide mais au moins
elles leur offrent de véritables séances
gratuites sur le divan alors selon vous
est ce que toutes ces émissions de
dating qui utilisent des experts sont
crédibles
la question à se poser n'hésitez pas à
donner votre avis sur les réseaux
sociaux
alors franchement monsieur sous terre
psychologue vous avez d un diplôme de
docteur en psychologie
quand on voit cette émission qui fait
polémique parce qu'il ya ceux qui
trouvent ça très bien et ceux qui sont
absolument choquée est-ce qu'on peut
réellement trouvé l'amour comme ça la
télévision grâce à l'or parce que vous
êtes vous êtes sûrs de trouver l'amour
une autre chose à trouver quelqu'un à
qui on le compare à la cépière voix se
marient
oui mais justement d'habitude qu'est ce
qu'on fait on tombe amoureux de
quelqu'un quand on est très très très
très amoureux on se marie et puis
malheureusement d'année en année ça
dégrade les déficits c'est d'inverser un
peu le processus je suis d'accord avec
vous ouais ouais
par cet amour dont on va d'abord essayer
de voir ce n'est compatir et puis
d'apprendre à s'aimer ou pas
effectivement des gens qui comptent
commandes assez mais d'autre part est-ce
que vous pouvez entendre la principale
critique c'est puisse choquer alors
c'est vrai on regarde ça un peu de façon
à là on va c'est un peu du voyeurisme
ça peut quand même choqué de présenter
des gens qui se sont jamais vus il se
rend compte directement devant monsieur
le maire quand même lu tout ce que
psychologiquement c'est pas un choc trop
fort non visiblement la plupart le gère
très bien donc je le reconnais
franchement que ça peut choquer
effectivement parce que des personnes
mettent parfois encore le mariage
républicain sur un piédestal mais pour
la plupart des gens qui comprennent que
c'est juste un contrat entre deux
personnes
avant la venue répondre tu permets de
page comme tu parce que comme par hasard
ces gens qui sont célibataires est
ringard du cul qu'on réduise et le
dosage des machines dépasser les
bâtiments importants parce que c'est
vraiment effectivement aujourd'hui il
faut d'abord voir si on est compatible
et ensuite monsieur à raison apprendre à
s'aimer tout et science aujourd'hui est
ce que vous savez qu aux états unis et
si aujourd'hui on peut choisir quand on
veut un enfant si on veut un garçon ou
navires non mais battus eux et on voit
bien que quand ce n'est pas science si
vous en êtes le premier témoin c'est le
même cas d'échec alors fait dynamo mais
non mais non à bouche pour savoir de
quoi on parle
j'aimerais qu'on s'intéresse à votre
technique de mobilité il ya évidemment
une technique et là on a un sujet on
regarde faire par jour d'après et aussi
compatibles sont leur vie sociale
ils ont nombreux amis sont tous les deux
très généreux très festif
autant de points communs qui vont leur
permettre de bien se comprendre et
d'être en accord avec la vie qu'il
souhaite mener ensemble
noreen a besoin d'un homme qui va la
stimuler intellectuellement et c'est
exactement ce que la sphère florian qui
s'intéressent à la lecture notamment aux
livres psychologique alors concrètement
pour match et les les gens sont encore
vous faites mais en fait c'est à dire
que si vous avez connu avant par exemple
j'aurais économiser beaucoup d'argent
par exemple pas ça fait longtemps que tu
dises et sleepy de nombreuses années 1
qu'est ce qui fait que des gens tiennent
biais gens tiennent pas notamment
évitement je ne mentionne il ya le
niveau socioculturel il ya les intérêts
et les valeurs il ya même des valeurs
politiques toute une série d'éléments
qu'on peut interroger les personnes pour
voir s'ils sont relativement dans le
même genre de vie parce qu'ils sont
contre quelqu'un dans une boîte de nuit
qu'on se trouve sexy est beau et
attirant
peut-être qu'après quelques temps on va
se rendre compte qu'on n'a pas du tout
les points communs seulement pas tout le
mode de vie non ça vaut la peine car de
poser la question jean est ce que vous
avez des points communs qui peut faire
qu'au moins ça peut tenir après sa
science devient pas mais au moins on
essaie de savoir s'il ya des choses qui
les rassemble moi je pensais que c'était
oppose et qui s'attire venise si on
prend les stades a coûté ma loge et
surprend les seat étudié aussi en france
sur neuf coups créé il ya un couple à
celle un seul qui tourne arrière plus
coupe de l'aff me semble-t-il c'est pas
du tout le couple qui était compatible à
la base il serait l'un pour l'autre
en vain les belles marques dire que
quatre qui sont en allemand en allemagne
quatre coupes et le pire c'est pourquoi
avant ses 25 % on attend en australie il
ya un couple sur twitter connaissent
mieux et après on avait envie de faire
un truc moi je regrette justement qu'on
ne voit plus les tests parce qu'elle
revienne partie à des tests
psychologiques et toute une série test
il ya des tests d'éthologie c'est à dire
l'état doit arrêter maintenant
moi j'ai fait des études de théologie je
peux vous dire c'est testera son
passionnant et magie c'est vraiment
français de l'éthologie masse et des
tests sur le comportement animal
documind aussi les phéromones les tout
ça j'ai fait à son offre les mariés avec
des doutes donc écologie et théologie ça
rime avec escroquerie hélas hélas
monsieur bonjour je suis très content
que vous soyez là ça me lis une
escroquerie intellectuelle et morale qui
bafoue le mariage républicain dont vous
parliez vous le fouler aux pieds dans
cette émission
cette émission elle est dangereuse vous
êtes des apprentis sorciers de l'amour
c'est honteux ce que vous faites
je vous rappelle que les gens peuvent
être détruits par ça évidemment qu'ils
divorcent tout l'attendait il s'agit
détruisent elle dit à l'est les bois je
crois les messieurs gilles moi je
comprends qu'on soit choqué parce qu'il
est extrêmement jeu le mariage est une
étude est une infusion institutions
l'institution fait d'accord maintenant
maintenant lise bellynck maintenant les
gens qui font cette mission sont
volontaires c'était une expérience au
titre de l'expo avec cette
expérimentation je peux me permettre une
téléréalité qui s'y connaît en mariage
mais non mais c'est là qu'est
l'escroquerie c'est qu'en fait ces gens
là c'est jeu c'est évident ils veulent
juste passé à l'abri des noms son mari
le père daniel je n'ai manière moi je
suis un cas désespéré je suis désolée
surtout ses filles non mais non
mais non elles ont toute la vie devant
elle chacun pour avoir vu l'émission est
plus fort que la science ou parliez de
crédibilité et la crédibilité elle
fonctionne à partir du moment où la
personne reste une deux ou trois
semaines
c'est qu'il y ait un résultat on l'a
prouvé par les statistiques en plus de
ça à par rapport au traitement du format
original oui on sait que barioz première
guerre c'est un format international en
france
le format est très proche de l'original
hélas cette année on s'intéresse à
l'après coupe là parce que tout ce qui
est processus de probabilité on les a
fait les années précédentes
il ya d'autres pays comme les etats-unis
qui seront macway je voudrais juste
terminer ma phrase
moi franchement je crois en l'amour
j'aime le mariage plus que tout je rêve
de me marier quand je vois cette
émission ça me fait vomir et calmez vous
va bien mais je dis simplement ce que je
pense parce qu'on joue avec le coeur des
gens on joue avec des gens qui sont
naïves comme moi qui crois en l'amour si
en même temps
en attendant ces saletés seuls savent
donc que sagna les candidats g koné ont
joué avec moi je moi je comprends je
vais vous dire franchement pour résumer
je comprends qu'on soit choqué par le
bar le côté mariages grands pins
effectivement quelque chose qui est tu
dois là c'est une vraie signification
suis bien placé pour le savoir mais dans
marié quatre fois je en même temps c'est
intéressant et c'est vrai que c'est
aussi un divertissement eysseric dans
cette émission le cheminement
même si ça peut nous choquer parfois
quand on voit la halle annonce aux
parents par exemple tous les ans je vais
je vais je vais épouser quelqu'un que
j'ai jamais vu mon look c'est assez
drôle
on vous a fait un pion un objectif la
garder et pour sa chaîne wii
et ils m'ont dit km à métro qu'en fait
si des experts m'ont appelé et m'ont
annoncé que les a vus retrouver un homme
qui est compatible à 83 % avec moi et
donc on se marrait dans un mois
c'est ça c'est assez drôle parce que
j'imagine que bon la gestion des proches
ça doit être assez compliqué complexe
moi je vous dis franchement c'est ça
c'est vrai à mes parents il aurait fait
don de tête sur c'est vrai ça montre
justement la sincérité des candidats
moi ce qui m'a vraiment touché 1 cette
mission c'est que la plupart des gens il
y en a quelques-uns qui viennent pour la
télévision on essaie justement de ne pas
les retenir ces personnes là d'ailleurs
où il n'ya pas de super bibeau et c'est
comme dans d'autres émissions de télé
réalité ont choisi vraiment des gens qui
sont tentés dans leurs démarches
et justement ils sont vrais et on voit
des parents qui réagissent réellement
d'inciter tromper vides hanté ça que je
trouvais intéressant c'est que c'est une
vraie expérience de personnes qui
choisissent en pleine conscience
ils sont ici connaissent l'émission y'a
pas une surprise de faire cette
expérience et on les voit qu'ils sont
vrais et authentiques autrement autre
moment très amusant dans l'émission
c'est quand les belles familles se
rencontrent donc le jour des noces sur
le banc que de la mairie là franchement
c'est moi moi ça me fait rire là
franchement c'est à vous regarder tu
rencontres de deux familles qui il n'y
aura absolument tout l'une de l'autre
mattel détendre l'atmosphère ou au
contraire renforcer les appréhensions de
chacun
[Musique]
bonjour nationale
je suis
un top 10 et 13 ans maman
la même chose mais oui sur ce coup là
oui combat l'aise le croisement des
regards où l'inconnu nuit gênante
oui monsieur faudra puis de la première
ce ne sont pas des mariages religieux
dont elle a évidemment très important de
dire pour gilles et la deuxième en
allemagne il ya eu 25 % de taux de
réussite c'est énorme
un mariage sur quatre a tenu et c'est
fait ce qu'on ne peut pas dire que pour
le moment ce ne sont que des hasards et
puis c'est un sommier
c'est un palier benjamas à dire qu'après
ils ont un oeil sur ce même s'ils
habitent et maintenant s'en fout ça oui
ça va c'est quand même un petit peu
importe où je m'en fous ils ont
plusieurs semaines pour cohabiter et
après qu un peu comme les voeux à la
religion il confiant oui c'est parce
alors être programme plus que ça voyez
pas aussi honteux que certains sur m6 m6
ou pas ça n'a pas d'intérêt
deuxième tentative max c'est sympa c'est
familial et le public ne s'y trompe pas
c'est pas des juges alors que
pierre-jean vous cette émission elle
vous amuse à job dit effrayé
merci et prier mais en même temps vous
savez moi je suis fiancée à régine alors
radeau date le bell labs un régime voilà
la clause la la la date des boîtes de
nuit mais bien sûr un vrai problème de
coût
même coiffeur chez carita donc donc je
suis un peu éloigné tout ça j'ai déjà
trouvé l'amour
alors comment ça se passe c'est
merveilleux c'est merveilleux miami en
ce moment à ma chérie à ehlg alors dit
même si un peu dylan méfie beaucoup de
télé réalité dont koh lanta c'était pas
forcément loin de là un dating vous avez
un peu bifurquer vers une carrière de
candidats de télé réalité c'est un peu
réducteur serait vous vous en pensez
quoi de les techniques de dating de la
façon dont moi je compte rencontrer
quand je fais de la télé réalité et on
se marie en france mais pas ensemble
comme et regard c'est à dire que même
nous a 20 ans on prend notre temps avant
de se demander sérieusement et je trouve
qu'elle aura à l'orage ce concert
tellement triste de se marier au premier
regard comme ça que j'ai regardé
l'émission vite fait il y avait des gens
ne trompe pas tout ça je trouve ça
regardez vite fait parce que se révèlent
les personnes qui participent à ce salon
ne fais pas ta capacité à séduire ton
charme sont des personnes qui ont essayé
plusieurs reprises rencontré quelqu'un
qui ont eu des échecs
ouais il espère que vraiment pour eux
dimanche qu'il fallait il ya des
personnes justement on prend les gens
comme ils sont merci à des gens qui ont
des physiques très classique très
éblouissant et d'autre des gens
ordinaires
alors pour conclure sur ce sujet selon
vous vous ne connaissez pas mais qui
pourrait être compatible sur le bateau
ça j'ai trouvé ma parfaite compatibilité
à 105% joue pas là bas moi à votre avis
par exemple mathieu francesca non mais
moi je suis de 2d l'autre de vous deux
finales voisine
[Applaudissements]
alors peut-être même en face la voulais
vraiment la même chose et donc avoir les
mêmes opinions avoir la même vision de
la vie sacraliser le mariage de la même
manière ça fait du sens
je pense que pour des gens qui ont
vraiment envie de fonctionner il faut au
moins qu'ils aient des points communs
des bases communes pour fonctionner on
n'a pas un petit extrait de vaud avec
votre fiancée si on a on a ça on va
regarder quand sur moi on a un truc non
pas torse alors on leur la primeur de
quitter lé président en prévenant
quitter les princes et princesses
peu importe ce qui se passe ce qui se
passera je leur souhaite de trouver
l'amour à tous parce que c'est quand
même le but de cette aventure je vous
souhaite de trouver la même chose que
nous encore une fois et
plein de bisous plein de bonheur ok
c'est vrai tout se passe très vite à
l'arrivée le moment présent vous prenez
pas la tête
qui fait quoi la villa dans l'est
un esprit dans lequel je suis accompli
j'ai jamais été aussi heureuse et aussi
bien dans aucune de mes précédentes
aventures
je revins d'ici en toute confiance et
peut-être avec l'homme de metz la preuve
la propre personne merci beaucoup de
nous voir vous êtes heureux vous wesh
vous allez vous marier toutes les
émissions elle fit km d'ici là fait
secret story en même temps mais alors
vous aussi
[Rires]